гібридна війна - це вид ворожих дій при
якому агресор не вдається до класичного
військового вторгнення а пригнічує свого
опонента використовуючи приховані
операції диверсії кібервійну
терористичні атаки та організовує
революційний рух на території держави
супротивника з формальної точки зору
така війна може тривати і в мирний
час
20 лютого 2014 року Російська Федерація
почала операцію з захоплення Криму і вже
в середині березня півострів перейшов
під контроль
Кремля окрім того в південних та східних
областях України російські спецслужби
організували серію громадських
заворушень та силових акцій метою яких
було захоплення влади створення
проросійських народних республік та
приєднання цих новоутворень до складу РФ
згодом забезпечуючи інформаційну
підтримку діям своїх спецслужб та армії
російські пропагандисти дали цьому
процесу романтич Харков Луганск Донецк
Херсон
Одеса попри те що в сфері інтересів
Російської Федерації була вся Східна
частина України успіху Кремль досягнув
лише у двох областях Донецькій та
Луганській і такий розвиток подій має
свою причину в умовах складної ситуації
на дипломатичній арені і банально
порожньої скарбниці держави Україна
спромоглась провести мобілізацію армії
та вибудувати
оборону
буквально ігноруючи нестачу палива
сучасного озброєння та навіть одягу на
Схід вирушили підрозділи збройних сил та
щойно сформовані добровольчі
батальйони всупереч усім проблемам і
труднощам були проведені перші
контратаки почалося українське
[музика]
літо станом на кінець
нелегітимно і росіяни примусять весь
світ не визнавати Україну і саме тому
принципово важливо для нас було провести
бездоганні
вибори з відповідною оцінкою міжнародних
спостерігачів ОБСЄ Євросоюзу Сполучених
Штатів Америки всього
світу а отже з урахуванням тривалості
всіх демократичних процедур дострокові
вибори президента були призначені на 25
травня 2014
року Логічно що відсутність обраної
влади в Україні грала на руку російським
спецслужбам Тож вони усіма доступ
методами намагалися проведенню виборів
завадити у східних областях України
протидія проведенню виборів мала силовий
характер і на цьому саме працювали
росіяни і в цьому була небезпека що вони
відбудеться почнуть наступ вторгнення
привезуть Януковича посадять його в
Києві і всьому світу скажуть ми
відновили конституційну
владу 7 квітня 14 року в Донецьку
Луганську і Харкові проросійські
сепаратисти проголосили про створення
Донецької Луганської та Харківської
народних республік відповідно
чи не першою метою яку переслідували
сепаратисти було взяття під свій
контроль усіх наявних запасів зброї та
боєприпасів а також встановлення своєї
влади Щонайменше у великих
містах увечері 7 квітня виконуючий
обов'язки президента України Олександр
Турчинов виступив із телевізійним
зверненням ми цього не допустимо
сьогодні вночі створено антикризовий
штаб а проти тих хто взяв руки зброю
будуть проводитись антитерористичні
заходи і дійсно вже 8 квітня рано вранці
силами спецпідрозділу Ягуар будівлю
Харківської Ода було від сепаратистів
очищено 65 осіб було затримано
стрілянини і жертв вдалось уникнути Так
звана Харківська народна Республіка не
проіснувала і
доби
зусиллями Степана полторака і
калинівського Вінницького ягуару
був без жодної жертви звільнений
врятований
Харків проте для повного відновлення
контролю над ситуацією країні сил не
вистачило і оперативно припинити
діяльність так званих ЛНР і ДНР не
вдалося
10 квітня Олександр Турчинов заявив що
влада не буде переслідувати тих хто
захопив адміністративні будівлі на сході
країни за умови що вони складуть
зброю того ж дня так званий голова
тимчасового уряду ДНР Денис пушилін
оголосив про початок формування власної
народної армії а вже за два дні у місті
Слов'янськ Донецької області України
з'явилися російські озброєні бойовики
під керівництвом полковника ФСБ Росії
Ігоря
гіркіна окрім того почався процес
безконтрольного розповсюдження зброї
серед місцевого криміналітету та осіб
які виявили бажання долучитися до лав
бойовиків реакцією на всі ці дії 13
квітня 2014 року Ради національної
безпеки і оборони України стало
оголошення про початок антитерористичної
операції що згодом увійшла в історію під
скороченою назвою АТО
arad
точені понад сотні місцевих жителів
прибули до воріт Маріупольської
військової частини номер 3057
це невиличкий підрозділ Національної
гвардії якій єдиний який був
розташований в Маріуполі
задум операції полягав у
демонстративному захопленні військової
частини та заволодінні зброєю був
організований мітинг на якому активісти
запропонували командиру військової
частини здатись і розпустити
військовослужбовців по домівках акцію
активно висвітлювали журналісти
російського телеканалу Life
News командування частини 3057 провело
переговори з бойовиками їх попередили що
у разі спроби проникнення на територ
частини по нападниках Буде відкрито
вогонь на ураження незважаючи на цю
обставину та прикриваючись цивільними
людьми бойовики розділилися на три групи
і розпочали штурм окрім використання
пляшок із запальною сумішшю бойовики
також вели вогонь зі стрілецької зброї
вранці перед воротами військової частини
було виявлено понад 70 стріляних гільз
різних калібрів інтервенти отримали
відсіч після попереджувальних пострілів
у повітря зон частини відкрив вогонь на
ураження розпочався бій з використанням
стрілецької зброї та гранат на допомогу
бійцям Національної гвардії прийшла
місцева міліція також щоб відігнати від
місця перестрілки цивільних осіб над
місцем бою на Малій висоті пройшли два
українські
літаки У підсумку частину було утримано
трьох нападників було вбито 13теро
зазнали поранень а 77 осіб було
затримано міліцією матери солдат пришли
поговорить с офицерами те без
предупреждения открыли огонь а потом ещё
обвинили мирных жителей в вооружеённом
нападении Російські журналісти видали в
ефір черговий маніпулятивний сюжет про
так звані звірства хунти а насправді ж
це був перший епізод коли у Маріуполі
бойовики отримали жорстку
[музика]
відсіч неспроможна держава англійське
failed State це держава яка не може
підтримувати своє існування як
життєздатна політична та економічна
одиниця це також держава яка стає
некерованою й недостатньо легітимною в
очах Міжнародного співтовариства у
зв'язку з розпадом державної влади на
розрахунковому рахунку в державному
казначействі знаходилося вже тепер вже
добре всім відомі 108 000 грн нема чим
платити заробітну платню ма чим платити
пенсію нема Але першим пріоритетом була
армія коли в золотовалютних резервах
держави було коштів менше ніж сума
необхідна для виплати боргових
зобов'язань держави Протягом наступних
трьох місяців через три місяці держава
банкрот коли падіння рівня волового
внутрішнього продукту жахлива
Коли все що вони хотіли вони хотіли
сказати що Україна fa State Україна
держава яка не
відбулося одним із напрямків роботи
російської пропаганди була спроба
створити враження що після революції
гідності Україна як держава перестала
існувати а На її території панує анархія
просуваючи цю ідею як всередині України
так і на міжнародній арені Кремль
намагався легітимізувати захоплення
Криму та представити вторгнення до
материкової частини України як
миротворчу чи навіть гуманітарну
операцію розуміючи ці прагнення одним з
важливих завдань українського
керівництва було налагодження
міжнародних зв'язків і протидія
Російській Федерації не тільки на полі
бою а і в сфері міжнародних
відносин До речі ще до виборів я мав
декілька важливих міжнародних візитів в
тому числі і до Парижа де ми проводили
переговори з ще як кандидат президенти з
президентом Франції французької
республіки паном
оландом і були досягнуті дуже вагомі
успіхи що по-перше ми отримали обіцянку
припинення військової співпраці з
Російською Федерацією в тому числі
скасування контрактів на
постачання вертольотоносців Містраль
один із яких до речі моїм останнім
аргументом було що один із яких х носив
назву владівосток а другий-
Севастополь і
е ми окремо проговорили і росіяни були
позбавлені цих дуже потужних штурмових е
сучасних засобів і я дуже дякую зараз за
це дуже болюче рішення для президента
Франції Тому що це є і робочі місця це є
і надходження бюджету це є і врешті-решт
голоси виборців французів
і
президент оланд продемонстрував що
відданість цінностям набагато важливіше
ніж голоси виборців він продемонстрував
себе як справжній державний
діяч торгнення до України
супроводжувалося і відповідною
інфокампанією з боку російських ЗМІ
співпрацюючи з бойовиками Російські
журналісти першим опинялися на місцях
різних інцидентів сутичок А пізніше і
терактів вони докладно висвітлювали
події в Криму а згодом і проросійські
акції на сході України інформаційна
політика Кремля щодо України була і є
агресивною але простою і вельми
прозорою критикуючи Всеукраїнське
помилки і прорахунки ефективно
висвітлюються всі Перемоги і здобутки
ігноруються чи
знецінюються Росі ЗМІ не гребують
маніпуляціями та часто відверто
брешуть всю весну 2014 року схід України
емоційно розгойдували російська
пропаганда використовувала головну зброю
інформаційної війни страх людей лякали
тотальною забороною російської мови
безробіттям і жорстокими репресіями
проти абсолютно усіх жителів Сходу
України зважаючи на широку популярність
та присутність російських телеканалів не
у всіх кабельних мережах України не
дивно що російські пропагандисти велику
кількість українських громадян банально
обдурили народное ополчение Мариуполя
выдвигается в помощь и поддержку
сражающемуся славянску 4 травня в мережі
Інтернет з'явилося відеозвернення від
так званих повстанців Маріуполя вони
заявили що висуваються для підтримки
оборони Слов'янська А у самому Маріуполі
почалося масове розповсюдження листівок
із закликом підтримати державну
незалежність ДНР на референдумі 11
травня згідно дійсного на той момент
українського законодавства місцевий
референдум не має законних підстав
відповідно його результати не були
визнані ні в Україні ні в світі Ні
навіть в
Росії у цих умовах українська влада
вжила серйозних заходів для того щоб
локалізувати райони дій російських
збройних формувань та запобігти
поширенню цього впливу на інші
міста зокрема почалося оточення
слов'янськокраматорської агломерації до
Маріуполя також були перекинуті
додаткові Українські
сили на Маріупольський аеродром зайшли
частини збройних сил навколо міста
виставили блокпости з бронетехнікою і ми
зайшли ми зупинились На блокпостах от Ми
перші блокпости виставили На в'їзді Біля
аеропорта на вїзді Маріуполь зі сторони
мангуша ми заходили ми стали на ці
блокпости і Азов зайшов в
середину увечері того ж дня біля
блокпоста неподалік села Мангуш відбувся
бій між бойовиками ДНР і бійцями
новоствореного батальйону міліції
Азов внаслідок бою один нападник був
убитий двох зокрема так званого міністра
оборони ДНР Ігоря хакімзянова було
затримано
9 травня 2014 року як на Донбасі так і
загалом по Україні відбувались
урочистості до Дня Перемоги у Другій
світовій війні у Києві депутати Партії
Регіонів комуністичної партії та інші
проросійські політики організували
покладання квітів у парку Слави
демонстративно прикрасивши себе
георгіївськими стрічками які вже встигли
стати символом
сепаратизму в Маріуполі з нагоди
пам'ятної дати також було організовано
велелюдний мітинг а близько 10ї ранку
біля будівлі управління внутрішніх справ
Маріуполя з'явилося кілька
автомобілів з них вийшли озброєні люди і
користуючись тим що велика кількість
співробітників міліції були задіяні в
охороні святкового мітингу почали атаку
на ув сили бойовиків налічували близько
25 осіб і були розподілені на дві групи
перша група кількістю у 10 осіб була
вдягнута в камуфляж і мала завдання
захопити будівлю ув Маріуполя друга
група складалася з осіб в цивільному і
мала блокувати рух на прилеглих вулицях
на початку травня начальнико міського
управління внутрішніх справ по маріуполю
був
призначений Валерій андрющук і він якраз
на 9 травня на ранок зібрав у себе
нараду з керівників підрозділів силових
які були в Маріуполі або біля нього це
було прикордонники МВС СБУ ЗСУ від ЗСУ
звісно тільки 72-ї бригада тоді була
всередині будівлі почалася стрілянина
для підтримки правоохоронців були
задіяні сили Національної гвардії та
невеличкий загін нещодавно створеного
батальйону міліції Азов окрім того в
місто увійшли підрозділи 20-го
батальйону територіальної оборони та
зведений підрозділ другого батальйону
72ї бригади збройних сил України два
батальйона вилетіли з своїх позицій
навколо Маріуполя і манша І ми тоді
полетіли в Маріуполь було прийнято
рішення командуванням перший батальйон
опять по блокпостам другий заходить в
середину спочатку атака на будівлю ув
лишилася непоміченою більшістю місцевих
жителів оскільки будівля була
розташована далеко від місць скупчення
людей однак просуваючись у бік
захопленої терори будівлі військові
зіткнулися з проблемою налякані і
обдурені пропагандою мирні жителі
перешкоджали руху техніки деякі з
присутніх буквально лізли під кулі та
заважали руху БМП не звертаючи уваги на
попереджувальні постріли така поведінка
місцевих жителів пояснюється тим що
проросійські провокатори розігнали чутки
про те що нібито українські силовики
атакують міліціонерів оскільки ті
начебто перейшли на бік бойовиків
ДНР пізніше про це також заявляв лідер
Комуністичної партії України Петро
Симоненко який заявив що міліціонери
відмовились виконувати наказ розганяти
проросійський мітинг ключовим моментом
подій 9 травня було те що основною метою
яку переслідували російські спецслужби у
цьому епізоді було створення атмосфери
страху і
[музика]
хаосу це в свою чергу використовували
Російські журналісти для дискредитації
сил АТО та української держави
прагнучи спровокувати велике
кровопролиття російські терористи вели
вогонь як по військових так і по юрбі
цивільних людей це призвело до поранення
щонайменше 20 та загибелі двох цивільних
осіб за іронією долі поранення від вогню
проросійських диверсантів отримав навіть
журналіст російського пропагандистського
каналу рашатудей фодор
завалійков наші військові їх небагато
перериваються до управління внутрішніх
Рав і мені доповідають що перший поверх
уже захоплений бойовиками уже
[музика]
іде бійка щоби піднятись на другий
поверх
а наші хлопці забрикодувались на
третьому поверсі і ведуть вогонь
відстрілюючись
від російсько-терористичних цих банд
угрупувань питають мені ХНУ Що робити І
я дав команду відкрити огонь по Першому
[музика]
поверху незважаючи на активну протидію
основне своє завдання силовики виконали
нападників від будівлі УВС вдалося
відігнати чотирьох бойовиків було
знищено але не варто забувати про той
факт що вдягнені у цивільні бойовики
візуально від мирних жителів не
відрізнялися такі провока ефективно
працювали з розлюченою юрбою та
підбурювали громадян на агресивні дії
проти силовиків як наслідок кількох
затриманих біля УВС терористів місцеві
жителі навіть у правоохоронців
відбили в результаті атаки на УВС
Маріуполя загинуло шестеро українських
силовиків начальника мійського
управління міліції Валерія андрущука
бойовики викрали і жорстоко катували 12
травня його вдалося викупити у
терористів і доставити в лікарню через
численні травми він місяць не міг
розмовляти переніс декілька операцій
тривалий час проходив реабілітацію але
на службу не
повернувся розуміючи небезпеку подальшої
ескалації та щоб уникнути значних жертв
серед цивільного населення військову
техніку та персонал з Маріуполя було
виведено одна з БМП вийшла з ладу та
після невдалої спроби евакуації була
покинута екіпажем проросійські активісти
в подальшому відбукси цю БМП вантажівкою
під будівлю міськради де Наступного дня
спалили варто визнати що окремі
представники міської влади симпатизували
російським бойовикам та надавали їм
усіляку підтримку за час поки тривала
операція біля будівлі УВС з метою
блокувати рух Української військової
техніки на вулицях міста було споруджено
досить серйозні барикади це могло
загрожувати зупинкою ко лонни техніки та
її захопленням як це було 16 квітня
поблизу Краматорська відео прориву такої
барикади коли БМП під номером 200
перелітає через перепону і пробиває шлях
іншим машинам буквально облетіло весь
світ маніпуляція суспільною свідомістю
навмисна дезінформація та підтасовка
фактів зробили свою справу 9 травня 2014
року в Маріуполі народилася легенда про
масові розстріли мирних жителів
українськими військами коментуючи події
російські ЗМІ спотворили всі факти та
тиражували моторошні чутки про цю подію
озвучуючи багатократно завищену цифру в
50 та навіть 120 загиблих взяли ребёнка
х лет мальчика маленького трусика
футболки прищеплення ненависті до
супротивника - це суть і мета пропаганди
в контексті війни і Російська Федерація
на держа ржавному рівні систематично
практикує таку пропаганду ведучи
інформаційну війну проти України як один
із аспектів збройної агресії і для
процесу роздмухування війни для
створення образу ворога з українців Як
Народу для залучення нової крові у так
звану армію Новоросії така брудна
Пропаганда просто необхідна кажучи
простими словами російські ЗМІ формували
свій Паралельний світ і готували свою
аудиторію до війни поя
їй причини чому треба брати до рук зброю
дарма що ці причини були ними ж і
[музика]
вигадані основним продуктом так званої
русскої вісни був хаос і задум Кремля
тут проглядається чітко безконтрольноз
роюючи кримінал та різноманітних
маргіналів на Донбасі російські
спецслужби одразу вирішували кілька
завдань по-перше в боях із силами АТО ці
Гарячі голови гинули самі і завдавали
втрат українським силовим структурам
по-друге бойовики перетворювали міста та
селища Сходу України на арену бойових
дій це в залежності від результату того
чи іншого бою дозволяло звинувачувати
українську владу або в геноциді власного
населення або в неспроможності побороти
кримінал або в обох цих гріхах
одночасно користуючись потужною медійною
машиною Кремль намагався створити ілюзію
того що лише російські силові структури
можуть навести лад на українській землі
Так під виглядом миротворчої операції
Російська Федерація готувала
[музика]
вторгнення вже в ніч з 9 на 10 травня
так званий руский мир показав себе у
всій красі бойовики пограбували кілька
збройових крамниць а також магазин
побутової техніки використовуючи тактику
живого щита проросійські налаштовані
громадяни змусили гарнізон частини
Національної гвардії 3057 полишити своє
місце дислокації в поясненні командира
цього невичкого підрозділу який був
розташований в Маріуполі пояснення було
таке що надто багато цивільних було
задіяно частина знаходиться навколо і е
житлові будинки і коли маса така іде
Людей То були дуже великі втрати серед
цивільного населення і саме тому
командир прийняв рішення
відступити 11 травня в Донецьку
Луганську слов'янську Краматорську
Маріуполі та інших підконтрольних
терористам містах пройшов референдум за
заявами так званого центрвиборчкому ДНР
явка виборців склала від 75 до 90% однак
ця інформація дійсності не відповідала
жодна з міжнародних організацій зокрема
ОБСЄ та Рада Європи своїх офіційних
спостерігачів на цей референдум не
надіслали обмежившись заявою про повагу
до результатів референдуму спостерігачів
не прислала навіть Росія реальна явка
виборців склала 24% в Луганській області
і 32% в Донецькій зокрема в Маріуполі
для проведення сепаратистського
референдуму було відкрито лише чотири
дільниці з 216 існуючих зважаючи на
незаконність референдуму та спротив як
деяких представників місцевої влади так
і громадських активістів отримати доступ
до реєстру виборців Бойовики не змогли
13 травня центр міста почали розчищати
від барикад і сміття це розблокувало
роботу міського транспорту мер Маріуполя
Юрій хотлубей підняв питання про
необхідність створення народних дружин
які мали б патрулювати місто разом з
міліцією і тут є важливий нюанс на якому
слід зупинитися окремо схід України - це
край промислових гігантів які переважно
є містоутворюючими підприємствами тобто
ці заводи є чи не єдиним місцем
працевлаштування для великої кількості
фахівців тож свого робочого місця
працівники тримаються зважаючи на таку
ситуацію керівники чи власники заводів
можуть впливати на настрой чи громадську
активність своїх робітників кажучи
Просто якщо хазяїн заводу виступає проти
відвідування його працівниками певних
мітингів чи зібрань то він має важелі
аби такі дії своїм робітникам реально
заборонити водночас Маріуполь також ще і
порт де завантажуються торгівельні судна
з усього світу тобто стабільна робота
Порту - це запорука отримання великим
бізнесом прибутку який потім у вигляді
податкових виплат поповнює і державну
скарбницю
як відомо великі гроші люблять тишу а
місто де бігають озброєні Бойовики не
краща атмосфера для ведення бізнесу тож
незважаючи на можливі ідеологічні
розбіжності промисловці Маріуполя були б
створені самопроголошених республік не
зацікавлені та з українською владою
співпрацювали проговорили з керівниками
підприємствами Я особисто мав зустріч із
паном ахметовим і з іншими і дуже
важливо що ці всі домовленості були
виконані ніхто не перешкоджав трудовим
колективам протестувати проти захоплення
Маріуполя російськими найманцями 28
травня лідер бойовиків Борисов провів
прес-конференцію де повідомив про масові
звільнення з металургійних підприємств
міста людей що симпатизували так званій
ДНР 15 травня на всі ко нальні та великі
підприємства міста від імені ДНР були
надіслані повідомлення у яких
представники бойовиків вимагали
підприємства присягнути новій Республіці
слід розуміти що Під словом присяга
мався на увазі перерозподіл податкових
та інших виплат увечері того ж дня
блокпост сил АТО розташований на виїзді
з міста у бік таганрогу вперше було
обстріляно з автоматичної зброї обстріл
вівся з боку новоазовська втрат вдалося
уникнути в ніч на 17 травня до Маріуполя
прибули озброєні представники Донецької
банди Оплот Вже наступного дня їхній
ватажок Андрій Борисов на прізвисько
чечен оголосив себе комендантом міста
від ДНР згідно з заявами Борисова його
люди прибули для підтримання порядку та
запобігання
мародерству подібна миролюбна риторика
була в той період серед бойовиків
популярною прикриваючись вельми
раціональними гаслами вони налагоджували
співпрацю з проросійські налаштованими
працівниками міліції та займались
створенням так званого Народного
Ополчення
рускамірці почали грабувати алкогольні
ма магазини почали грабувати людей на
вулицях бізнесменів приїжджати до них
додому і силовими метода Ну от вибивати
все що можна тільки 20 травня баватажок
бойовиків Борисов дозволив усім хто
записався в ополчення заходити у
будь-який магазин Та не платити за
товари першої необхідності такі як їжа
медикаменти та військовий одяг окрім
того Борисов дозволив не сплачувати
кредити та пообіцяв погашення
судимостей паралельно цим подіям сили
АТО готували операцію по зачищенню міста
від бойовиків попередній план передбачав
звільнення міста від терористів 23
травня 2014 року цю дату було обрано щоб
забезпечити проведення у місті Маріуполь
демократичних виборів президент
підготовка до яких незважаючи на
протидію з боку терористів велась майже
на усіх виборчих дільницях це взагалі
складова військової освіти цьому вчати
при всіх військових інститутах і
академіях про те що дійсно дії в місті
це досить таки складно говорячи про
спроможності збройних сил України на той
час я би так категорично не заявляв що
до цьогоми були не готові скоріш за все
найбільш правильним формулюванням буде
були готові але обмеженої кількості сили
засоби тому що у різних військових
частин у різних підрозділів був разний
ступень і об'єм бойового досвіду в тому
числі досвіду в населених пунктах звісно
не таких крупних як Маріуполь але був
розуміючи всю складність ведення бойових
дій в умовах міста та беручи до уваги
нестачу сил і велику небезпеку жертв
серед мирного населення звільнення міста
відтермінували однак вибори в Маріуполі
все ж таки відбулися ні залякування
членів виборчих комісій ні перешкоджання
доставці виборчих бюлетенів ні погрози
городянам у день голосування з боку
збройних банд формувань не стали
перешкодою волевиявленню
маріупольців бюлетені для голосування
таємно були доправлені у місто
військовим літаком і до Дня виборів
зберігалися на аеродромі Маріуполя
частина дільниць не відкрилася деякі
почали роботу з запізненням охорону
дільниць замість міліції забезпечували
нечисленні вірні присязі співробітники
СБ прийти на вибори дійсно було страшно
навіть ті люди які хотіли дуже невисока
була явка здається
15% але зважаючи на той факт що із-за
мирних обставин вибори зазвичай
відвідувала лише третина містян в умовах
окупації 15% це досить
багато вже за кілька днів в Україні
з'явився новий президент і
головнокомандувач
одразу після виборів у місті Маріуполь
група бійців батальйону Азов провела
розвідку боєм зав'язавши нетривалу
перестрілку з бойовиками поблизу їхнього
штабу на вулиці грецькій втрат жодна зі
сторін Не зазнала Наступного дня кількох
публічних осіб які агітували за ДНР та
співпрацювали з бойовиками бійці
батальйону Азов
заарештували 28 травня озброєні бойовики
пограбували торговий центр примор'є 2
червня угруповання чечена захопило
інкасаторський автомобіль ПриватБанку
окрім того було скоєно вісім епізодів
викрадення місцевих бізнесменів семеро
сплатили грошовий викуп і відбулися
тілесними ушкодженнями одного заручника
убили в місті почалось мородирство
почали грабувати магазини почали там
знущатись над людьми тобто вони такого
щастя в апках не
очікували незалежно від своєї природи чи
походження будь-яка армія потребує
забезпечення харчами паливом та
боєприпасами якщо бойові дії тривають
досить довго то окрім їжі та патронів
солдатів ще потрібно одягати та лікувати
від бойових поранень і звичайних хвороб
всі ці нюанси російське керівництво
завжди чітко розуміло і перші колони
забезпечення гібридної армії перетнули
російсько-український кордон вже у
середині квітня
року українські командири незважаючи на
брак бойового досвіду вчились
військовому мистецтву за тими ж книжками
що і супротивник а отже важливість
контролю шляхів забезпечення також чітко
розуміли підготовка штурму та зачистка
Маріуполя передбачала блокування міста
силами військових окрім того готувалась
операція з блокування державного кордону
метою якої була повна ізоляція сил
бойовиків Отже на початку червня
підрозділи 72ї бригади почали передавати
свої блокпости навколо Маріуполя 23му
батальйону територіальної оборони
Запорізької області
Хортиця зважаючи на ущільнення облоги та
бойові дії що точилися На інших
напрямках підвезення в Маріуполь
озброєнь і боєприпасів як наземним
шляхом так і по воді було серйозно
ускладнене військові збройні сили
вони відрізали
Маріуполь
від комунікації з донецькою областю і в
першу чергу з Донецьком де були
сконцентровані основні сили
російсько-терористичних
угрупувань забезпечення гібридної армії
Кремля відбувалося шляхом підвозу
вантажів з території Російської
Федерації для приховування цього факту
російські пропагандисти проводили
відповідну інформкомпанію та постійно
розповідали про те що бойовики
використовують зброю і боєприпаси
начебто захоплені у збройних сил
[музика]
України варто зазначити що після
проведення виборів президента українська
влада набула необхідного рівня
легітимності щоб протидіяти Російському
вторгненню не тільки на полі бою а й на
дипломатичній арені і Отже одразу же
після перемоги на виборах в мене були
уже візити в Варшаву де я мав окрему
дуже продуктивну зустріч з президентом
Сполучених Штатів Америки бараком Обамою
і була дуже важлива зустріч з в
Нормандії де рішучими зусиллями бо Путін
знаєте як
висклизав зустрічі вся всіляко намагався
заблокувати зустріч в форматі чотирьох
коли Франція і Німеччина організували
таким чином щоб зустріч відбулася і
Путін взяв на себе зобов'язання зупи
нити агресію і звільнити українську
землю незважаючи на численні
організаційні проблеми блокування силами
АТО міста Маріуполя дало позитивні
результати не маючи відповідного
забезпечення людьми та технікою ваташки
так званої ДНР так і не спромоглися
перетворити свої банди на армію однак ця
обставина не заважала їм учиняти
поодинокі теракти та банально грабувати
підприємців і мешканців
міста за результатами проведеного в
Маріуполі 6 червня соцопитування лише
третина респондентів повідомили що
довіряють представникам так званої ДНР
на той час епіцентром бойових дій були
околиці міста Слов'янська та прикордонні
території де бойовики атакували
українські застави з російської
території 5 червня сили АТО звільнили
від терористів перше окуповане місто Це
був населений пункт Лиман Донецької
області Вже наступного дня у небі над
слов'янськом бойовики використовуючи
новітній російський зенітний комплекс
9к333 верба збили український
фоторозвідник
[музика]
ан-30б
7 червня відбулась інавгурація нового
президента
України на церемонію прибули 56
міжнародних делегацій які тим самим
визнали легітимність нового глави
держави України у своїй інавгураційній
промові новообраний президент Петро
Порошенко зазначив що він прагне досягти
Миру готовий надати амністію
сепаратистам які не вчинили серйозних
злочинів готовий забезпечити коридор для
російських інтерве ті щоб вони могли
безпечно повернутися на територію
Російської Федерації президент Порошенко
також зазначив що поважає використання
російської мови у східних регіонах
України та не має намірів забороняти її
на цих територіях унікальність виборів
того часу була в тому що жодної скарги
жодного судового позову настільки було
це організовано і проведено чесно
прозоро без використання
адміністративного ресурсу в принципі
тому що Ну ми Були відповідальні перед
майданом події перших днів літа показали
що від здатності України до контролю над
державним кордоном буде залежати перебіг
усієї кампанії отримуючи від Російської
Федерації важку зброю бойовики діяли все
агресивніше 12 червня бойовики отримали
з території Росії перші танки тобто так
чи інакше але кордон потрібно було
закривати контроль над кордоном і
створення 10тикілометрової буферної зони
вздовж межі було одним із ключових
пунктів Мирного плану який запропонував
новообраний президент Петро Порошенко з
військової точки зору кордон треба було
контролювати щоб відрізати терористів
від поставок зброї з РФ завдання з
відновлення контролю над державним
кордоном було покладене на збройні сили
України створюючи вздовж кордону
контрольовану смугу завширшки 10-20 км
армія надійно ізолювала б терористів від
російських спонсорів як наслідок це
призвело б до виснаження запасів палива
та боєприпасів у Слов'янську та інших
ключових точках протистояння 12 червня
збройні сили України розпочали операцію
з блокування державного кордону за добу
було блоковано перехід кордону трьома
автоколонами зі зброєю і боєприпасами
захоплено 10 вантажівок з озброєнням
знищено кілька позицій бойовиків та два
Танки які щойно при були з Росії ударом
гелікоптерів було знищено ще одну колону
яка прорвалася на українську територію
втрати російських бойовиків склали
близько 40 чоловік убитими було знищено
12 одиниць автомобільної техніки того ж
дня в Маріуполі було затримано так
званого народного мера міста Олександра
фоменка кілька годин по тому було
звільнено Маріуполь
8го числа
було визначено остаточний план ігра і
операції уже ної в якості президента при
безпосередній участі Турчинова Авакова і
військових успішне звільнення Маріуполя
від бойовиків - це результат правильно
спланованої і чітко виконаної операції з
залученням як Національної гвардії так і
Збройних сил для запобігання жертв серед
цивільних осіб центр міста Де був
розташований штаб сепаратистів блокувала
маріупольська міліція
в тій операції були
задіяні
Нацгвардія Тобто ми Азов були задіяні
ще інші підрозділи Нацгвардії були
задіяна
армія власне власне зушка яка була на
вулиці грецькій з іншої сторони то була
армійська зушка основною метою був штаб
бойовиків на вулиці грецькій дорога
власне грецька на підход до барикад була
замінована під прикриттям вогнюкулеметів
та автоматичної гармати зу-23 штаб був
зачищений до вечора був відновлений
контроль над усіма адміністративними
будівлями у місті 13 червня 2014 року
над будівлею міськради міста Маріуполь
було знову піднято український
прапор ця перемога має свої об'єктивні
причини по-перше було вдало обрано час
проведення операції рано вранці вулиці
міста були пусті окрім того Незважаючи
на заклики з боку активістів
комуністичної партії цивільні люди вже
не заважали діям сил АТО не блокували
рух техніки і не лізли під кулі до того
ж тверезо оцінюючи баланс сил
напередодні штурму частина бойовиків
зокрема і їхній лідер кинувши зброю
сховалися або ж навіть залишили місто
Коли почали там стріляти вони всі
повтікали вони з приміщення фактично
повтікали бо ми їх
виловлювали вже на території приватних
секторів бій за Маріуполь не був легким
у ході операції поранення отримали
шестеро українських бійців п'ятеро
терористів було вбито понад 30 осіб
затримано незважаючи на серйозний
масштаб операції Ніхто з мирних жителів
не постраждав рез декілька літ світ
побачить велику країну і то буде то буде
моя Україна
Україну 13 червня 2014 року було
звільнено Маріуполь Це була важлива
перемога однак війна не
скінчилася Вже наступного дня терористи
банди Восток атакували колону
держприкордонслужби України одна
цивільна особа та п'ятеро українських
прикордонників загинули ще семеро
військовослужбовців отримали поранення
того ж дня над луганськом було збито
український транспортний літак іл-76 на
борту якого загинуло 49 українських
військових більш ніж на місяць
епіцентром уваги ЗМІ стали Слов'янськ
Донецьк Луганськ та прикордонна
територія позначена на військових мапах
як сектор д ведучи війну проти України
Кремль активно використовував
українських же громадян російські ЗМІ
сіяли ненависть і розбрат просуваючи
ідею що начебто Київська Влада бажає
Донбас за ті чи інші гріхи знищити задум
Кремля жорстокий але простий опираючись
вторгненню Україна вимушена вести бої на
своїй території всі руйнування
тягарем на Державний бюджет кожен
постраждалий місцевий житель має свої
певні причини звинувачувати у своїх
бідах саме українське військо А
російські ЗМІ допоможуть цьому
громадянину забути Хто насправді першим
почав війну зважаючи на такі процеси
протидія російському вторгненню
відбувалась одразу за кількома
напрямками одним із способів були
численні спроби припинити бої та сісти
за стіл перемовин дав можливість і
оголосив
тиждень позиції щодо припинення
вогню і сказав що ми виставляємо
абсолютно чіткі позиції виходу
російських окупаційних військ
роззброєння не законних збройних
формувань
і кави в бойовиків а отже армія та
підрозділи Національної гвардії наступ
на їхні позиції відно
Протягом наступних шести тижнів сили АТО
звільнили Слов'янськ Краматорськ Бахмут
Лисичанськ севіродонецьк дебальцеви та
велику кількість інших населених пунктів
Сходу України у більшості випадків
руйнування і втрати цивільного населення
Були невеликими тож окрім воєнної
поразки гібридна армія Кремля зазнала
ідеологічного фіаску обіцяний
російськими ЗМІ геноцид рускоговорящего
населения так і не розпочався а першим
що військові привезли
війни Російська Федерація віроломно не
обґрунтовано і без оголошення війни
напала на
Україну слід розуміти що виснажена в
боях українська армія вже зазнала на той
час важких втрат у людях і техніці
натомість російські сили вторгнення були
свіжі та готові до бою незважаючи на
локальні успіхи українська оборона
буквально розвалилася вже вдень 23
серпня російські війська почали наступ
на південній ділянці фронту у напрямку
Маріуполя фронт впав за принципом Доміно
де відступ одного підрозділу призводив
до загрози оточення сусіідів і змушував
їх також відступати оперативно зібрати
залишки військ не вдалося вже увечері 23
серпня поблизу амвросіївки лінія
української оборони припинила своє
існування
на територію України увійшли вісім
батальйонних тактичних груп збройних сил
Російської Федерації загальна
чисельність цих сил склала близько 4 000
солдатів російські війська розгорнули
наступ у бік северодонецька Тореза та
Маріуполя дорога на Іловайськ де тривали
жорстокі міські бої була
відкрита 25 серпня російські війська
почали обстріл Маріуполя добре
пам'ятаючи що таке руский мір частина
мешканців міста заради власної безпеки
того ж дня почали
виїздити 27 серпня розвідники які
відступали від савурмогили виявили
скупчення російських військ поблизу
амбросіївки зв'язавшись із командуванням
мобільним телефоном вони передали
координати і характер виявлених цілей о
10:30 по російських військах було
завдано групового удару ракетами Точка У
внаслідок влучаня табір супротивника
було знищено детонація боєприпасів
тривала до 7ї вечора цього ж дня на
маріупольському напрямі було виявлено
велику колону російської техніки яка
прямувала у бік бойківського протягом
дня російські війська у взаємодії з
бойовиками зайняли кілька прикордонних
сіл на схід від
новоазовська одночасно тривав наступ у
бік Маріуполя і на луганському напрямку
тривали бої на південних околицях
Донецька та біля Дебальцевого окрім того
російські сили вторгнення блокували
Українські війська поблизу міста
Іловайськ 28 серпня точилися бої
неподалік хрящуватого новосвітлівки і
луганського аеропорту російські війська
захопили Новоазовськ і дорога на
Маріуполь була фактично
відкрита намагаючись протидіяти загрозі
українське командування стягнуло
південніше Волновахи всю наявну важку
артилерію з цих позиції важкі рсзв смерч
і ракетні комплекси.чкау могли працювати
як у напрямку Іловайська так і
прикривати Маріуполь і незважаючи на
вартість ракет ніхто не шкодував 29
серпня російсько-терористичні сили
закріпились в місті Новоазовськ та
розпочали підготовку до наступу в бік
Маріуполя 30 серпня так званий штаб ДНР
заявив про захоплення Волновахи та
оточення міста Маріуполя однак ця
інформація дійсності не відповідала і
жодного бойовика у вказаних містах і
селищах помічено не було активне
застосування тактичних комплексів точка
у Та рсзв смерч певною мірою дозволило
затримати наступальний порив російських
броньованих груп російська армія
втратила убитими і пораненими до 300
військовослужбовців але склалася
ситуація при якій боєздатних військ на
ділянці між Донецьком і Маріуполем
виявилося критично мало
в бій були кинуті всі ресурси від
особистої охорони Президента і
підрозділів Спецназу Управління
державної
охорони до підрозділів Нацгвардії які
стояли на охороні атомних
електростанцій зважаючи на ситуацію що
склалася жителі міста активно долучилися
до будівництва додаткових
фортифікаційних споруд свій внесок в
оборону міста Зробив також місцевий
великий
бізнес
безумовно Це мало дуже велике значення
тому що те угрупування військ яке на той
час існувало в Маріуполі воно не мало ні
інженерної техніки не спеціальної
техніки для обладнання позицій для всіх
цих
питань однак обороняти Приазов'я було
фактично Нічим а підрозділи які були
розташовані поблизу Маріуполя не мали
достатньої кількості важкого
озброєння зважаючи на ситуацію що
склалась генштаб України прийняв
нестандарт рішення яке в результаті
виявилося
правильним до складу нашого угрупування
На той період була
передана
батарея
ураган практично дивізіон 55ї
бригади Ну і відповідно дві танкових
роти які На той період вийшли на
швидкоруч Було зібрано всю наявну
артилерію яка мала не шкодуючи снарядів
і ракет стріляти по усіх виявлени ціля
щоб завдати противнику що наступав
максимальної шкоди розвідку цілей було
покладено на невеличкі розвідувальні та
рейдові групи які переважно формувалися
з десантників окрім визначення позицій
противника ці групи виконували і
демонстраційні дії вводячи супротивника
в оману створюючи ілюзію присутності в
приазов'ї Великих сил а у противника
з'явився відповідно так званий
Приморський фланг для наступу і
оволодіння ну практично другим по
величині містом Донбасу великим
промишленим адміністративним центром
Маріуполь
редові дії своєю тою мали демонстрацію і
створення уявлення У противника про
існування угрупування наших військ на
глибині континентальної частини в таких
умовах будь-який розвиток
наступу вздовж морського узбережжя з
відкритим континентальним флангом він
теряв будь-яку перспективу відповідно
будь-які більш-менш вагомі шанси на
успіх для рейдових дій були сформовані
чотири тактичні групи по дві від 95ї і
79ї бригад Ці групи мали різний склад
але кожна мала приблизно 10-15
бронетранспортерів з десантом та
підтримку артилерії в ніч на 2 вересня
біля новоазовська розвідники виявили
скупчення військ і техніки російської
арміїв вказаних цілях було завдано
потужного удару частина машин і
особового складу були знищені в ніч на 3
вересня підрозділи 95 і 79ї бригад
висунулись в район Березівки і
Добропілля відповідно і вже вранці
розпочали рейдові дії я не хочу говорити
що ми поспішали але діяти були вимушені
досить таки динамічно тактика була
простою але дієвою зустрічаючи позиції
терористів десантники наводили на них
артилерію а потім атакували з двох боків
не затримуючись довго на одному місці
просуваючись безперервними боями рейдові
групи пройшли досить складним і
заплутаним маршрутом бої З терористами
та російськими військами відбулися
поблизу вугледара володимирівки
Благодатного новотроїцького оленівки
миколаївки та
докучаївська Вже наступного дня штормові
загони вирушили у бік Маріуполя
демонструючи Як терористам так і своїм
громадянам що за містом маріу
держава Україна буде битися проте
росіяни не втрачали часу і після
захоплення новоазовська на початку
вересня 2014 року вийшли на околиці
Маріуполя де-факто місто готувалося в
тих подіях до оборони не тільки ділянка
місцевост а в цілому місто готувалась до
оборони кілька днів на початку вересня
2014 року були вирішальними для долі
міста слід розуміти що з огляду на
фактичну відсутність реально боєздатних
частин на цій ділянці фронту десантники
в першу чергу виконували демонстраційну
роль буквально створюючи видимість
потужного угруповання українських військ
і ці дії були
успішними завдяки ефективній взаємодії
десантників і артилерії противнику було
завдано великої шкоди
наша арта була додатковим аргументом до
десантників які проводили рейд для того
щоб росіяни
зрозуміли їх поховають якщо вони
продовжать танковий рух на Маріуполь ми
я вперше це кажу ми їх там
чекав успіх операції лив стримати наступ
на Маріуполь та певною мірою додав
козирів у руки українських
переговорників у Мінську як наслідок вже
5 вересня було підписано так звані перші
мінські
домовленості до Маріуполя російська
армія не дійшла 5
км
переговори ведуть лише з тими кого
складно
завоювати на початку вересня 2014 року
під великим питанням було існування
держави Україна і без перебільшення долі
мільйонів
людей збройні сили і добровольчі
підрозділи буквально кістками лягли на
шляху російських
загарбників для відновлення втрат і на
фронт новостворених підрозділів був
потрібен час був необхідний
тайм-аут Мінський мир від 5 вересня 2014
року змінив небагато війна лишилася
відкритим питанням і Маріуполь зазнав ще
чимало атак і терактів але перемир'я
дозволило перевести подих немов боксер
після декількох важких раундів виснажена
літньою кампані армія стала в глухий
захист вчепившись за висоти і
річки зіткнувшись із запеклим і
відчайдушним опором І зазнавши
несподівано важких втрат при вторгненні
в Україну Росія прийняла умови Мінського
Миру станом на 2021 рік
російсько-українська війна
триває